[Music]
do you have lots of hype asset tables
that you want to migrate to bigquery
migrating high asset data from hadoop to
google bigquery is a fairly
straightforward process
in this video i am going to show you how
to migrate hive assets to bigquery
i am anu
strategic cloud engineer in google
let's get started
what are
hive tables
asset enabled hive tables support
transactions like updates and delete
operations
we will explore how to migrate hive
asset tables to bigquery without the
dependency of performing major or minor
compaction
acid is an acronym for atomicity
consistency isolation and durability
it guarantees the database transactions
are processed in a reliable way
underlying hype asset table files or an
orc asset format to support asset
features hype stores table data instead
of base files and all the insert update
and delete operations or in delta files
it creates a lot of small delta files
and then hive metastore runs major
compactions in the hadoop cluster to
consolidate these base file and delta
files into a single file or into a more
manageable file set
some of the challenges are
name node capacity problems due to
small delta files
also storing a lot of small files cannot
be efficiently handled by hadoop file
system
reading through small files involve lot
of c corporations
it takes longer for data replication to
dr due to these extremely small files
also table locks during compaction so
non-asset sessions can not access the
high asset tables
another challenge is running major
compactions on high asset table is a
resource intensive operation
google bigquery is a server-less highly
scalable cloud data virus it allows for
super fast queries on petabyte scale
data some of the benefits of migrating
these hive asset tables to bigquery are
once the data is loaded into the managed
bigquery tables bigquery manages and
optimizes the data stored in the
internal storage and it also handles
compaction so there will not be any
issues like small file issues we have in
hadoop
the locking issue will be resolved as
the bigquery reads and writes are highly
performant and are highly parallelized
as orc files are completely
self-describable there is no dependency
to extract height ddls
bigquery has an inbuilt
schema inference feature that can infer
the schema from the orc file and it also
supports schema evolution without any
need for data processing tools to infer
the schema
these orc files in an asset table are
extended with several columns like
operation original transaction bucket
row id to uniquely identify the
transactions there are two main steps to
migrate high assets to bigquery
first copy the underlying orc files from
hdfs and stage these files in google
cloud storage
second
load these orc files to bigquery assets
copy the files under the hive table and
stage the files in google cloud storage
using the nifi based hdfs to gcs
solution published by google pso team or
use disk or people you don't have to
compact before copying these files to
google cloud storage
then load these orc files into bigquery
perform bqload access to a base table in
bigquery
here is the schema of the base table
this space table will have all the
transactions
recorded
write a query to reflect the updates and
delete transactions
and load into a target table
use the dvt tool published by google pso
to validate the schema and data of
height asset table and the target
bigquery table
the way hive manages the underlying data
is different from the way bigquery
manages the underlying data
the pain points of high asset tables
like small files issue compaction issues
locking issues are resolved when
migrating to bigquery
there are a lot more scenarios to
explore when it comes to high migration
but i am sure this will give you a good
starting point
if you are interested in exploring
automated hdfs to gcs knife based
solution and data validation utility
please check out the link in the
description
to understand more about migrating data
viruses to bigquery i highly encourage
you to check out the public
documentation link that i have posted in
the description
thank you for your time
thank you for watching